[Musik]
ich habe gar keine erwartungen an das
heutige video get fit with summe das
sofa workout sommer macht sport sind das
überhaupt lesen da hinten
dabei macht sport ist das video auf dass
wir heute reagieren werden von unserer
lieblingsschauspielerin aller zeiten
halt das hier ist das video auf dass wir
heute reagieren werden bevor wir jetzt
allerdings auf play klicken schauen wir
uns erst mal einige kommentare unter
diesem video an wie viel wiegt ohne ein
like ein kilo und 1483 likes wer wartet
auch schon auf die nächste reaction von
luca dollar hat hinten genauso viel
brust wie vor 99 prozent von gomez
gehirn besteht aus essen und dann halt
noch tausende weitere kommentare von
wegen ich soll darauf reagieren
ja mach ich ja jetzt heute gerade und
wir haben für die heutige reaction auch
wieder einige pingo sätze vorbereitet
die ihm ihr unter meine letzte doppel
reaction geschrieben habe marianne gibt
unmenschliche beleidigungen
beziehungsweise schimpfwörter von sich
dumme ist am falschen zeitpunkt etwas
also beim abnehmen oder unter mariannes
aufsichts tonne was machst du da wo soll
das denn landen ich will auch nicht zu
den olympischen spielen bommel was hast
du denn jetzt vor was machst du ja mal
abwarten ob heute einen bingo satz drin
vorkommen wird war in den letzten beiden
doppel actions kann ja kein einziger
lingus hat drin vor ort und daher klicke
ich jetzt mal lieber direkt auf play
okay doch geht mit ihrer tochter und mit
tante marianne zum piccolino das ist ein
kinder
spielparadies ich weiß jetzt schon
worauf dass sie mehr auslaufen wird dann
habe ich diesen süßigkeitenautomaten da
gesehen und der weg zu dem kinderland
der war ja schon so anstrengend hungrig
gemacht dann habe ich an der seite
dieser gedacht
will jetzt auf diese rolle hier drauf
gehen
viel glück
slater aber die sich gerade aufhalten
die rannte zu dem süßwaren automat das
ist so ein verfassen ist leider fehlt
verfressen das luder schon als marianne
beleidigung
das war ja hier der kommentar aber ich
glaube das zählt noch nicht verfressen
ist du das jetzt nicht so exotisch wenn
ich bin was willst du denn hier
kommentare was hast du denn jetzt vor
nicht ganz und denken über den roller
nach meine liebe das ist nicht gekommen
ich bin so dass im hintergrund hält noch
eine kamerafrau von rtl rumläuft es die
aus dem bild gehen das muss nicht sein
verfahren im kinderland ist doch genauso
als wenn im café gehst mir wird gesagt
aber er wurde ja kein kuchen
da es war der ford und hingeht windtner
war da dieser als automat mit dem
betroffen heisst der weg schon richtig
neuen kohl die 1 es ist zwar noch nicht
passiert aber das wird der erste bingo
gewinne heute sein name ist am falschen
zeitpunkt etwas also beim abnehmen oder
unter mariannes aufsichtspflicht
kameraaufnahmen gerade wenn du so
weitermachst bricht das ganze zu retten
also ja herzlichen glückwunsch an stan
ist anschein hier
du hast den ersten renault platz belegt
diesmal ich gratuliere dir von ganzem
herzen
[Applaus]
das geht nicht kaputt ich wollte er nun
münchen darauf ohne mich ja irgendwie
aus geklatscht und macht er macht ja
auch sinn nein nein jetzt die gehen
jetzt nicht nein jetzt nicht wirklich zu
dem auto scooter da alter comedy
highlights kurzum kommentare wirklich
hinten mehr brust als manche mädels
fordere ich hoffe ihr versteht dass das
hier alles nicht ernst gemeinte
beleidigungen oder irgendwie sowas sind
ich feiere doch ungemein im doppel falls
du das video gesehen sollte sich helga
bock das will man zusammen video
aufnehmen aber wir schauen erst mal wie
die ganze situation am autoscooter jetzt
vonstatten geht
das fand ich so peinlich riefen die über
lautsprecher die dicke frau aus vagen 7
möchten bietet den wagen verlassen
ist das haben die rausgeschnitten die
dicke frau aus vagen 7
[Applaus]
also die szene mit dem autoscooter wird
wohl irgendwie aus diesem video hier
raus geschnitten
deswegen haben uns gerade mal einem
gesonderten video angeschaut aber jetzt
geht es weiter mit donnerstag im
spieleparadies ich weiß auch gar nicht
warum es bisher geld für du bist doch
als das herz sie eigentlich nur ein eis
gegessen
nichts gegen dumme aber ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob sie auf das gerät passen würde
variante ehren frau alter das muss man
einfach so sagen die unterstützt die
doppel wo sie nur kann
[Musik]
auf dem weg zum sport laden zieht die
sich sechs donuts rein
also ich finde schon immer krass wenn
ich im gym bin und dann leute da raus
gehen und sich danach irgendwie so ein
fleisch wurst brötchen mit butter
reinziehen
doch mehr ist das absolute ultimatum
kann man das irgendwie verlängert wird
sowieso von sofa bis zum kühlschrank
wäre das nicht
nein da fand ich habe nicht gesagt dass
hat wenig gesagt um so fergusson
couscous
immer wenn ich mir so eine folge von
donna angeschaut habe muss ich dann nach
drei stunden yoga machen kriegt man ja
irgendwie zuschüsse vom amt für nein das
sicher nicht also ja nicht unsere käufer
die kaufen das so ja dann könnte ich
ihnen gleich was andere empfehlen wir
dem trampolin
ja
trampolin hat er gesehen wie verdoppelt
haben muss natürlich drauf ich war als
kind mit dem trampolin zu einem
trampolin verein ein trampolin und
bitten den damen sind es die das jetzt
auch noch mal eben ein paar sekunden
später
ich sag dazu einfach gar nichts mehr das
ganze ungehört so das war schon ganz
schön anstrengend und der verkäufer hat
mich gelehrt
ich dachte er sie hätten schokoladen
automat hat mir den text mit köpfen ist
allein dass jetzt schon wieder so
unfassbar schwitzt da diese auf einem
laufband umher gefahren und hat drei mal
auf dem trampolin gehört sich auch so
versetzen und fernseh gucken dabei und
dabei dann noch abnehmen das war doch
schon immer mein traum ich will da
gar nichts mehr zu sagen ich weiß nicht
ob die elektroimpulse bei diesem großen
überhaupt ankommen bei ihrem vater
und das versuche ich habe auch richtig
gemerkt dass mir das ist doch das könnt
ihr noch die chips sommer ja kommt die
nachos reifen geil alter super m hat
sich dem körper ja auch wieder was zu
führen an energie man muss sich das mal
vorstellen als kameramann da sitzen zwei
etwas dickere frauen wenn die marian ist
auch nicht gerade die allerbeste sitzt
auf dem sofa und beugt sich über
muskelstimulation rtl ii den finger so
unter sonntag gefasst habe ich voll ein
gewicht gekriegt was tust du dir denn
dass ich sagen ist du solltest dir ein
sportgerät kommen und nicht so ein
scheiß die hastig gegessen hat oder wer
weiß das gibt es doch wohl nicht wie
dumm ist
[Musik]
du gibst du mir echt leid die will ja
kein was zuleide tut und einfach nur
abnehmen aber trotzdem halt dabei noch
chips und schokolade ist und dabei
fernsehgucken adam ich wünsche auf jeden
fall noch ganz viel glück auf seiner
reise allerdings würde ich damit das
heutige video ist auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch meine reaktion
hierauf get fit wird doch gefallen hat
ich weiß jetzt nicht wo sie wirklich
sport gemacht hat aber irgendwie ja es
ist halt doch nicht das video gefallen
hat haben das gerne einen daumen hoch da
schreibt mir jetzt und in die kommentare
weitere bingo sätze von dem gedenk dass
sie nächstes wochenende wenn ich auf die
nächste folge mit dem reagieren werde
wenn ihr denkt dass dahin satz von
vorkommt dann schreibt den unten in die
kommentare weg darauf abonnieren wenn
sie noch kein abonnent von meinem kanal
sein und falschen abonnenten klick gern
auf die glocke denn dann bekommt die
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen
[Musik]